YEAH. ALL RIGHT. GOOD MORNING
ALL THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR
THIRTY JULY EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER. PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT
AN AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDING IS BEING
MADE. AND IS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED. MEMBERS OF THE PUMP
ATTENDANT A SERMONS WERE MASK
AT ALL TIMES. ATTENDEES MUST
ALSO REFRAIN FROM CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OUR OTHERWISE
MPS THE ORDERLY CONDUCT THIS
HEARING. VIOLATION OF THE RULES
MAY SUBJECT AN INDIVIDUAL TO
REMOVAL OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS. I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT WE HAVE TODAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VALLADARES. WHO IS HERE
FOR HER FIRST. RULES
GRANDPARENTS ARE WELCOME HERE
SUZETTE AND- WE WILL MEET AGAIN
NEXT WEEK IN THIS ROOM AS WELL
OF ITS PROGRAM THAT WAY SO MR
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CLICK HERE. SENATE LARA GIPSON
THEY'RE VERY YEAH MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS YOUR RAMOS RUBIO YEAH
CALAVERAS. YOU PUT. OFF HERE
WEBER. WE HAVE A CAR WE A
QUORUM HAVE AGAINST AGENDA.
MOVER MISTER MATHIS SECOND OF A
MISTER GIVE. A MISTER SIR
PROVED THE ROLL. COOLEY HI-
COOLEY AYE BENNETT LARA GIPSON-
GIPSON HIGHLY THE AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS AYE MATHIS AYE RAMOS
RAMOS I RUBIO. RUBIO HIGH
VALLADARES CALAVERAS HIGH V.
APPROVED LAW HE PUT LA HI
WEBER. WEBER HI WATSON PASSES.
VERY GOOD- THAT MOTIONS PASSED.
WITH THE- NUMBER AND THIS WHAT
IS ADJOURNED. THANK YOU FOR
MUCH IS THAT THEY CAN JOINING
US. A LOT OF THE HAVE YOU.
THANK YOU. GROOM